it's another day heading into work for
brian kulas and it's no easy commute to
get to his job as a banquet server it's
160 kilometers almost two hours each way
from his home in east brunswick new
jersey to his job in atlantic city
he doesn't do it by choice but out of
necessity it's the only job he can find
where he makes enough income to survive
each month but barely
people i don't always think realize what
it's like
to have to live on half a penny
you know
i call it sometimes splitting pennies
brian is one of an estimated 125
million americans who live paycheck to
paycheck it's now even made harder by
rising inflation for many years the
inflation rate in the u.s hovered around
2 percent but it's been steadily
increasing this year to where it's now
about 5 and a half percent
the highest it's been since 1990.
food rent energy new cars those are the
sectors that have seen the biggest price
jump and economists say it only takes a
slight increase in inflation to cause a
huge impact
the perception that inflation is a
problem could lead us to make some very
bad choices in terms of the economy if
we god forbid raise interest rates right
now while unemployment is still elevated
that could be a real economic disaster
anti-poverty advocates say inflation is
only a small part of a bigger problem
the income inequality that has been
growing over the last few decades is
really the key concern we've had wage
stagnation
in this nation since the early 1970s
and wages have for decades not kept up
with the high
increases in costs of living
for brian he faces a new challenge his
landlord raised his rent he can no
longer afford it so he'll be evicted
next month
it's like taking a look around because
i can't afford to live here i don't
belong here
you know it's a really nice place but
i'm out you know only because i can't
afford it
he says if he can't find anywhere else
to live
that car he drives to work will also
then become his home
gabriel lozando al jazeera east
brunswick new jersey